[Music]
i'm very pleased to be joined now by my
friend megan basham a reporter for the
daily wire a rotten tomatoes critic the
author of beside every successful man
megan thank you for being here
always thanks for having me so you are
here to educate me because i am reliably
informed that the oscars are coming up i
have not watched the oscars in
years at this point i'm not sure that
i've seen
any of the oscar-nominated movies nor do
i really know what they are and so i've
got two questions one
what is going to happen at the oscars
what should we look for and two
are americans going to care or have they
completely tuned out hollywood
well i think that's one of the things
that you need to watch for because i
think ratings wise this is probably just
going to be a dumpster fire i mean the
reality is that oscar ratings have been
trending down for years but last year
they they reached an all-time low really
bad now some of that you can ascribe to
covid
but the fact is they were already on a
downward trend and the academy has been
losing money and abc has been losing
money on this deal i mean they they
still make some revenue but to give you
an idea uh
oscars brought in 15 million dollars
less in advertising revenue last year so
that's a really big deal so what you can
expect to see you would think would be
let's reverse course maybe the americans
at home do not like the political
speeches maybe they don't like having
their values
derided and insulted and mocked
well that's not what the academy
ultimately decided they looked at the
declining ratings
and they said we think the problem is
that people just really don't like that
sound editor they don't like that film
editing category they want to get rid of
the poor little guys who to be honest
with you that is my favorite moments
those are my favorite moments in the
oscars is when you see these guys who
are not celebrities they're not well
known they get their big moment they're
never political they always thank their
wives and seem really sincere so what
they've decided to do is cut those guys
out of the show
wow because i agree with you i used to
watch the oscars as a kid all the time
and i thought those were some of the
most enjoyable categories you know the
celebrities they always get the
attention and the accolades so it's fun
or or you know the short film category
some random person who you've never
heard of gets up and is just very
sincere and thanks the academy it used
to we used to joke that uh you know the
way to give a proper speech as you go up
and say i just want to thank the academy
and now
you basically don't even see that you
see someone go up and say donald trump
is really bad and men are really women
and and abortion is really good and okay
now maybe we'll be played off because my
my personal political speech has gone on
for so long that you know we're going to
run out of airtime
so they've they've doubled down on this
well yeah and you have seen them uh
showing some gratitude in recent years
it's been uh female actresses thanking
the their abortions for
their their performance i mean we have
seen that michelle williams did that i
am grateful that i had an abortion so
that i could be here tonight so they
don't consider that maybe that is what's
driving viewers away instead they think
nah it's just these categories some
fairly important categories like i don't
know film editing seems like it's fairly
important to making a film yeah but so
they're doing away with that so they're
part of the reason is they're saying
this is going to streamline it they
think that more time with the stars that
people find off-putting is what is
really going to bring viewers in
and then this is the real kicker
they went who could we get to host this
show to bring in viewers and what they
settled on was primarily amy schumer
the most political off-putting comedian
in the comedy landscape i have to
correct you i have to correct you megan
you called her a comedian
okay you're right
that seems generous
it does seem generous and wanda sykes
and regina hall who look i think wanda
sykes can be funny but she is not a big
draw for middle america and regina hall
most people don't know at all i don't
know who she is i'm just hearing the
name for the first time right i mean she
has she's been in some small movies she
um she had a a recurring role on the tv
show blackish
and i think to a lot of people it seems
like after the me too movement after
black lives matter they went we will
have a black lesbian
comedian we will have a black comedian
and we will have a white comedian but
they'll all three be females no men on
that stage hosting
and you know i look at it and i go i
don't see how this is
in any way going to draw anybody into
watching this show so i think those are
the two main things to look for as far
as the movies
you know there were some that i liked
but i'm going to tell you the these are
very um other than dune
these are not films that most people
have seen um you there's movies like
power of the dog which is another gay
cowboy movie coda was a good movie but
you know it's about a child of deaf
parents it was actually a sweet movie
but it's not very well known um so you
just have a lot of films that people
haven't heard of they haven't watched
and they're not going to care how many
gay cowboys are there they've been
making these movies for decades now i
mean more than 20 years at this point
you i guess you you saw this
really begin
30 40 years ago this split between
movies people see
and movies that nobody sees maybe you
and i see i used to occasionally go see
some kind of indie movies the gay cowboy
thing never did much for me but some you
know you and now even even for me it's
too much and i like the artsy kinds of
movies so
you've got this split now is it is there
ever any uh turn back that we can hope
for that you're gonna see a popular
movie be nominated again
well you know and actually it sort of
affected the entire film landscape in a
way that's really negative because they
used to try to make really good popular
movies movies that were popular that
could also qualify as a best picture and
now you've seen such a split that the
art house movies are getting more and
more more esoteric less appealing to the
general audience whereas the popular
films they're all superhero movies which
you know i like a superhero movie but i
would also like some other popular
movies as well
so i think that that is part of the
divide that's going forward and i don't
know i i think probably not because of
the streaming revolution our content has
become all the more fractured so
quite honestly i i see no sign that
they're going to pull back from
irrelevance here i guess it's a step in
the right direction for the academy that
they were able to get a host this year
because after the kevin hart debacle no
one wanted to host anymore it was the
it's sort of like the giving the
republican response to the state of the
union it's the worst job it's the end of
your career and nobody wants so they
would have a hostless oscars
not entirely true ricky gervais said
i'll do it and i don't know why they
said no thank you to him which that
would have really brought some viewers i
was really too bad if they really wanted
people to watch the oscars this year
they they would have taken ricky gervais
up on his offer it it does make me
wonder i'm looking now at what what the
democrats are doing but forget hollywood
for a second what the democrats are
doing politically is in an election year
in a midterm election year they are
doubling down on letting men go into the
girls locker room and take girls
trophies doubling down on abortion as a
some kind of sacred right up until the
moment of birth they're doubling down on
mass migration they're doubling down on
all the same sorts of radical policies
that the vast majority of americans do
not like and you've seen them be rebuked
for it at that virginia governor's race
you've see they're getting absolutely
crushed in the polls right now and yet
it seems that the worse their numbers
are the more they double down and that's
kind of what you're seeing in hollywood
i mean the people who run hollywood
they don't have a low iq all right we're
not talking about really stupid people
so they must know that the majority of
americans don't like this stuff anymore
and what's their answer amy schumer one
of the least funny most
nauseating shrill politically annoying
she's the niece of chuck schumer for
goodness sakes you know that's the
answer that that they've got to their
problem
well and i think part of it is you know
they're just listening too much to the
hollywood press and the activist
employees in their own houses you've
seen parents who are sort of driven by
their obnoxious children in a really
true way that is what we're seeing at
studios you look at the disney debacle
this last week and you go
you have actually some conservative
leadership there who had
a correct instinct when they said we're
not actually going to talk about the
florida bill we're just going to focus
on doing good work putting out movies
that people like and their employees
went insane
the hollywood press then of course
amplified all of that insanity and
you're talking about a very small sliver
of people who were able to drive
disney's
agenda in a way that is against its
better business instincts so and they
know it that's what's weird is i talked
to some very high level executives this
week at disney who told me
we know we know about the daily wire
polling we know that parents don't like
it but at this point there's such fear
of the negative press there's such fear
of getting blasted on msnbc that they
are reacting they're not thinking this
through this reminds me of a line in
politics they say personnel is policy
what they mean by that is the people
that you put in charge are much more
than any little document or memo or
frankly constitution even the people you
put in charge of running your company
your organization your government they
are going to set the policy it's them
you look if you've got a lot of crazy
hair and weird tattoos and crazy
left-wing t-shirts that that is going to
be the policy that you're going to get i
noticed this even with with republicans
even republicans in left-wing
institutions left-wing universities
left-wing corporations
they will get much squishier because
their view of the country is so
distorted
they're only around liberals they read
the new york times they think that this
represents the majority of americans
when it represents a very small portion
of them antonin scalia gave an interview
with new york magazine years ago now and
the the interviewer was mocking him for
believing in the devil for believing in
god for believing and he he took a pause
and he looked at her he said
she was laughing at him and he said
do you realize
how out of touch you are with the
majority of them the majority of people
throughout history have believed in god
and believed in the devil do you realize
what a crazy bubble you're living in
that you think that this is not just
wrong but uncommon
right and that was the strangest thing
to me you know to talk to some of these
guys and hear that
they know and yet they're under the
perception that they are going to be
more damaged by this negative press than
they are by let's say stories that
reflect what ron desantis has done and
said we're going to stand strong or i
don't know fire some of these crybabies
and these cry bullies i've heard it
called and that really is what they are
cry bullies within these organizations
who are you know they're they're in the
mail room trying to tell the board what
to do and the board is letting them so
the insanity of the the lack of
leadership is
it just kind of blows your mind though
it did blow my mind to hear that some of
these guys high up in disney
listen to daily wire and watch daily
wire products well i do love that i hope
they check out my docu-series fouchy
unmask maybe then we'll get some good uh
good policy coming out of the
administrative state because
you know what you're describing is the
inmates running the asylum and and but
it actually is just striking me now when
we say these hollywood execs they're not
dummies okay they're they're well
educated they've got high iqs
maybe they just feel that the political
power in this country the power that can
really threaten them
it's not the people it's not even really
the customer base
it's the liberal press it's the woke
employees it's the blob it's just that
kind of big liberal blob there actually
might be something to it megan in just
the few seconds we have left where can
people find you
oh well you can find me at the daily
wire of course and uh you can find me
once a month now on andrew clavin's show
which is probably the favorite my
favorite part of my month we uh we get
to chat about culture and entertainment
and all of these you know great things
that make life more entertaining and
more worth living and and you can always
find me fighting with people on twitter
meg basham that's great you know i that
is enough to get me to tune in to drew's
show to tune in to the andrew clavin
show once a month
[Music]
[Music]
you